hey guys justin here with the gamespot
news update the halo master chief
collection has been plagued with
matchmaking issues since its launch but
developer 343 Industries has talked
about some of the solutions that it has
in store the executive producer of 343
industries and a letter posted on their
website said that they are working on a
solution right now in the meantime we'll
be rolling out additional tweaks over
the next days to further improve the
experience while we ready the solution
in order to make things as smooth as
possible for now 343 will be temporarily
disabling some playlists in an attempt
to drive the population to the matches
that are working best specifically team
hardcore rumble pit halo 4 and SWAT are
to be disabled he also writes that most
matches should get you to a game within
four minutes if it takes any longer than
that you should exit the search and
restart as this will increase the
likelihood of finding a match he went on
to apologize for the current situation
adding we won't rest until it's what it
should be people are reporting
improvements across the board which is
great but we're not backing down until
we finish this fight when there are
further updates and patches to the game
will have the full scoop over on
gamespot com / news